today the Democrats engaged in a bit of
theater in a desperate effort to keep
the Russian collusion drama going Jerry
Nadler Judiciary Committee along party
lines voted to subpoena the entire
unredacted mother report in all
supporting evidence from the Department
of Justice if the department still
refuses then it should be up to a judge
not the President and not his political
appointee to decide whether or not is
appropriate for the committee to review
the complete record now understand this
with this move Nadler is a committee
that might again party line vote it's
actually committing a fraud it's a fraud
if ultimately filed at the Justice
Department on the Justice Department and
just the discussion of it it's a fraud
on the American people any judge
considering this should sanction any
lawyer who signs his name on this
request for a subpoena given that the
law prohibits Attorney General Barr from
releasing underlying materials without a
careful review for any grand jury
information that would be prohibited by
law to release the Attorney General's
entire mandate is to enforce law and
he's expressly forbidden from providing
grand jury outside the department in a
very limited and narrow exceptions
Congress is not one of the exceptions
and the Chairman knows it well this
isn't serious come on it's it's all just
a dumb show never mind that Muller found
no criminality in his two-year probe and
that there is nothing in the report to
justify impeachment which is what the
Democrats obviously wanted Nadler and
his crew are just trying to distract
from their own embarrassment and for the
Democratic Theory here to be correct
think about what has to be bill Barr an
internationally respected legal mind in
former Bush Attorney General would have
had to knowingly distort Muller's
fact-finding on both collusion and
obstruction and to Muller Barr and most
everyone involved in this investigation
would have to be in some way in cahoots
working to protect the president at all
costs now tonight we do have reports
from the New York Times that there are
anonymous investigators from the Muller
team
who feel that bar summary was incomplete
well the report doesn't say who was
upset in the New York Times or what
they're really upset about it's kind of
murky we'll wait and see if anything
comes of that but why would Muller stand
by without objection
if bar had skewed in his his lengthy
findings its 400-page of report right in
a four-page summary
well answer mother wouldn't do that now
remember it only took him hours to
correct a false report from BuzzFeed
earlier this year and also remember both
Republicans and Democrats went to great
pains to build Muller up as a consummate
Pro an upstanding citizen and legal mind
he chose robert muller who has so much
integrity there is literally no more
respected person in American law
enforcement than Bob Mollica judgment
character integrity humility if you have
a kid and you despair that there's not a
hero in America wake up bright-eyed and
bushy-tailed Robert Muller said I think
the Republic
just got a chance of saving itself okay
so now we're to believe that this
sainted figure mauler has become either
muzzled or in some way manipulated fat
chance even now bill Barr is working to
redact the Mullah report in accordance
with the law in order to release it as
promised probably by mid-april here so
why the Democrats in such a rush well
what's going on here because they are so
invested in this grand tinfoil hat
conspiracy that they've forgotten how to
govern and they've forgotten how to
judge issues such as this very important
dispassionately hatred for Trump it's
their animating principle and they must
constantly feed their media and
political beefs beasts who have been
sharpening their teeth to devour Trump
since the night he won the presidency
and I think in this twisted world of
resistance it doesn't matter if the case
against Trump evaporated
they'll just create another one they're
addicted to hating Trump recall how high
with anticipation they've been we're
seeing that the collusion piece of this
piece-by-piece starting to be built out
it's gonna be you know a political
hurricane is out there and sees for him
we'll call it hurricane vladimer if you
will the walls are closing in he seems
cornered and he's lashing out we are
finally at a tipping point the walls are
closing in on President Trump they're
closing and all right
but not on Trump so now the media and
some of the other resistance types will
do anything to avoid kicking their hate
Trump habit no mayor culpas here
Democrat media and co-conspirators are
seeing their ratings collapse but they
reject the idea that an intervention is
it any way necessary they're on a path
of self-destruction illusion is a
behavior and there could be ample proof
of that kind of behavior in Muller's
full findings this could set up a
political battle with this perception
that President Trump is trying to shield
certain information from the public it
feels like the seeds of a cover-up are
here the flames of conspiracy must be
kept burning the get Trump gang requires
new injections to reach the resistance
euphoria that once felt so exhilarating
now just yesterday CNN and MSNBC found a
truly sensational new morsel for their
audiences
you're not just saying he cheats you're
saying he cheats I mean he cheats on all
of it he cheats like a mafia accountant
like he cheats crazy he tried to cheat
Tiger Woods in a match and they all come
up to me told me how they do it they
have four balls in the pocket and either
instructors throw it out of any bunker
or out of the woods aren't no Palmer
would be rolling in his grave about the
big orange splotch he's putting on the
game that I love golf game it is
hilarious watching them flail but then
again it it really isn't because the
idea that political and media partisans
should have to work this hard to create
an anti-trump narrative even as the
facts escape them it's sort of tragic so
what next Hamburglar in chief what the
president's diet tells us about his
presidency
or Hair Force one what's under Trump's
ball caps and why it should concern you
tomorrow my friends activists from
dozens of far-left groups are themselves
promising massive protests nationwide
keep it going got to keep it going
what the purpose of the protests well of
course anyone with a brain knows it's
about collecting email addresses for
2020 that's what it's really about but
what they claim the protest tomorrow
gonna be all about is that they want to
pressure bill bar to immediately release
the entire unredacted Mullah report and
all the underlying witness interviews
and so forth this is truly moronic if
bar or any Attorney General bowed to
some organized protest and abandon the
classified information redaction process
he or she would risk serious legal
jeopardy but who cares you know concepts
like the rule of law they mean nothing
to these people whose sole purpose in
life is to resist Trump by any means
necessary
so tomorrow along with their release the
report signs the protest organizers
should really be passing out tinfoil
hats but my question is what happens
when they run out of conspiracy theories
what then who knows but until then it'll
be more sound and fury signifying
nothing
and that's the angle